how many screenplays did you write
before final destination I think about
seven and these were feature yeah yeah
seven features of varying degrees
starting from really awful - okay - good
cuz that yeah I wrote my first one I was
in middle school no high school and I
sent it to line cinema to get coverage
on and I'm like oh I got great coverage
but it's not right for us and then when
I started working at new line like five
years later I dug the coverage up and
they were like this is awful
it was obviously written by a middle
schooler I was like I was in high school
so it's interesting because I that I
always just tell people like that's why
you you can't take rejection when you
get it because if I'd have seen that
coverage when I was that in high school
I probably would have just been like oh
I don't have any talent Oh - given up
but you also have to be open to growing
you know cuz I also meet a lot of young
people and you know God bus I'm you know
but they just they think that they're
already there they're like you know how
you know I'm like this script script is
the best thing you know Holly was ever
gonna make and it's like you're 15 I'm
sure that with all due respect I'm sure
that's not the best thing that Hollywood
its kind of gonna read so you know you
need to kind of let your ego go and
realize it you have to have to grow so I
was very I wrote a lot um I didn't again
just learning you it's a learning
process but I just it was a when I
was young it was just a lot of fun you
know just to write and then you know you
start loading structure as you get you
know older and then when you start
working at a studio then all of a sudden
you start realizing oh there's a hard
craft of this that you need to kind of
learn - so it's mixing the business with
the creative and this was a script based
loosely on like Nightmare on Elm Street
that was one eye that was a treatment I
wrote when I was 14 which I wrote I'm
gotten - hello cat a little visitor here
that I wrote for a night run Elm Street
and that's what got me in touch with New
Line Cinema when I was 14 and I stayed
in touch with him till I was 19 and I
started interning there when I was 19
and so yeah they made they made final
destination when I was 30 just to date
myself but um but um the first
finalization originally started off as a
spec script to get an agent for an
x-files episode because they want you to
write something you know of your own and
they also want you to write something
that's already on TV so that you can
show you can write different characters
voices so I wrote is x-files episode and
I didn't submit it to the show because
when my friends at New Line said this
will make a great feature and then I
worked on it and it ironically ended up
with two guys who worked on the x-files
James long and Glen Morgan so it was
kind of a I think I think it was kind of
a karmic thing you know that's kind of
meant to be with the x-files connection
there I'm curious so what is keeping in
touch was that like that's fascinating
Oh fourteen you're like yeah I'm just
gonna be keeping in touch with new line
well no but well cuz that you because I
you know Bob Shaye at first he didn't
read my treatment because it was
unsolicited and then I wrote him kind of
a snarky snarky but you know kind of a
you know I was like hey I've seen three
of your movies and I spent money on you
I think you can take five minutes to
read my story yeah yeah so so he did and
you know got back to me and and then his
assistant would you know her name is joy
man she's like just amazing woman would
you we had she passed years ago
unfortunately but just amazing woman and
she would send me like movie posters and
like little you know merchandising
things for the movies that she was
sending scripts to read so I just would
stay in touch with them and send them
scripts and you know they were always
very very gracious to even spend time
with me and when they I don't know if
they ever knew I was actually gonna get
to New York or not but I ended up at my
collar I was pretty crafty I should be
craftier I make a good supervillain if I
if I use my craftiness for evil but um
when I was in college we started I had
to do a special program where I could go
to New York for the summer to study
acting the American Academy of Dramatic
Arts and then would get credit for it so
they the school paid for my whole trip
to New York and my whole summer there
but then I got an internship at new line
while I was up there and got an agent I
was like ah screw school and decided to
stay to stay in New York and stay at new
line so so that so was they knew you
were 16 or however old you were when you
sent the script in yeah I think yeah joy
I think I don't know if I heard I don't
know when I told Joe how old I was I
think she asked me one because I I would
call her - I got the phone number from
information so I would just call her and
she would she would talk to me oh that's
right yeah I mean and this was back when
new line was you know I mean nightmare
had come out so they were they were
definitely growing but they hadn't
turned into like the powerhouse that
they that they became
you know it definitely wouldn't that
wouldn't happen today but um you know it
was a real blessing I you know I always
give credit to Bob and joy for you know
just if they hadn't stayed in touch with
me and inspired me and then brought me
on as an intern when I first started you
know in when I went to New York I mean
I'm sure I still would have been in the
business like that just was my path I
think but um but yeah they were they
were really crucial and I missed them I
mean Warner Brothers like absorbed new
line so it you know it's not the same
place anymore but it was it was probably
one of the best I think studios probably
to ever be built because it was so
artist friendly and you know they really
cared about like the be Amy Bob Shaye
was a huge film lover like he started
distributing like John Waters films out
of his apartment to college campuses and
doing like these tour like so he's a
huge film lover so he created this
company that was full of film lovers and
now you have a lot of great companies
but a lot of them are run by business
people who don't love film so they they
understand the equations of like you
know well if I put this formula together
it'll make money but they don't
understand the creative side of it and
new line was just just a wonderful like
fostering environment to work so yeah I
got really lucky with that one so your
first year there as an intern you were
19 yeah do you remember what that was
like I mean it must have been surreal
because here's this group of people that
first they turned you down but then they
keep in touch with you and they send you
things and now you're there it's some
it's it was it was surreal in a way but
it was kind of it's a weird thing just
because I always knew I was gonna be
working in a movie business somehow like
I didn't get except I wasn't like super
like he would hit me sometimes but it
didn't hit me when like when I found
that coverage for that first thing I
wrote it I was like wow if I'd have read
this if they did tell me the truth I
might not be here but because it was
kind of all happening and you're again
when you're younger you know you're so
like 19 you're still at that like I can
do anything in the world and I think
it's not me and you know so I never I
always have always been so appreciative
of the opportunity but I wasn't like I
was ever surprised
you know but it was cool it was really
cool like because I never got to meet
all the people from Nightmare on Elm
Street and so meeting all these people
that I had grown up idolizing was like
cool and I remember we were at the 7 new
line did you know 7 this amazing movie
with Brad Pitt and Morgan Freeman and
we're at the premiere for that and I'll
send I'm talking to Morgan Freeman for
like an hour around like you know
because they teach you when you work
they're like don't act weird around when
the celebrities come in because they
would come in all the time for meetings
so you just said that you'd learn how to
like kind of shut that geeky part off of
your brain right right sometimes but
then I you know I had lunch with Jane
babbler who was in V the miniseries that
came out in the 80s and played the Diana
the the evil like lizard alien queen and
that I liked I had lunch with her and
that was a first time I've actually been
starstruck were like I couldn't talk
like it was read it because I never knew
what starstruck meant until I had lunch
with her and then I was like I can't
talk right now and I can't this is
really embarrassing I'm a grown man and
why might like this but yeah it's it's
um again it was it was it was a
wonderful thing and it was a wonderful
convergence of again the right people
like Bob enjoy like taking the time
because even you know Bob could his hurt
and in that one thing in written me off
and joy could have been like oh that's
cute and you know but you know she did
she would stay in touch with me and I
probably just for one I probably bugged
the hell out of her I was always like
say do you read this can eat it and she
was just very patient and yeah just it
was yeah it was a wonderful experience
it was
you